Alice:我困了刘婷
其他人：睡
Others: Sleep.
Alice:待着能能睡吗
Alice: Can you sleep just sitting here?
Alice:我还想说你怎么把我的枕头拿走了
Alice: I was wondering why you took my pillow.
Alice:我一看枕头在我
Alice: Then I saw it was with me.
其他人：血口喷人你真是的
Others: You're making false accusations, seriously.
Alice:我刚看见他说打扫二楼
Alice: I just saw the message about cleaning the second floor.
Alice:20分钟之前发的怎么办
Alice: It was sent 20 minutes ago, what should I do?
Alice:你等着我吧
Alice: Just wait for me.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Alice:刚看到消息
Alice: Just saw the message.
Alice:这有用吗这还
Alice: Is this even useful?
Shure: 猜猜这一坨是谁压的
Shure: Guess who pressed this?
Alice:这坨东西还有用吗
Alice: Is this thing still useful?
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 很有用
Shure: Very useful.
Alice:搁哪
Alice: Where do you put it?
Shure: 这几个是谢彬竹的那个我靠
Shure: These are Xie Binzhu's... oh my.
Shure: 还有一个应该
Shure: And there should be one more.
Alice:那要不你给他收起来
Alice: Why don't you keep it for him then?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Yeah, right.
Shure: 这四个是谢彬竹的
Shure: These four are Xie Binzhu's.
Shure: 这个是杨老板
Shure: This one is Jake's.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 杨老板这个是什么的
Shure: Jake, what is this for?
Jake:哎
Jake: Huh?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:12345有5个
Jake: There are 5 of them, 12345.
Jake:这边不用翻
Jake: No need to flip this side.
Jake:这一层就5个
Jake: There are just 5 on this layer.
Alice:这是不是搬下去啊
Alice: Should we move this down?
Alice:这个木凳子
Alice: This wooden bench.
Alice:搬一个
Shure: 这也说不用
Shure: No need for this either.
Shure: 搬下去就放这了
Shure: Just move it down and place it here.
Shure: 哎呀音箱拔下来
Shure: Oh no, unplug the speaker.
Shure: 哎音响已经拔了
Shure: The speaker is already unplugged.
Shure: 音响我想直接寄回家了
Shure: I think I'll just send the speaker back home.
Shure: 反正我在学校应该也用不到了吧
Shure: Anyway, I probably won't need it at school.
Alice:西瓜什么时候买的
Alice: When did you buy the watermelon?
其他人：刚刚
Others: Just now.
Alice:刚刚
Alice: Just now?
其他人：我们俩刚刚出去了一下
Others: We just went out for a bit.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure: 因为没买到刮刮乐
Shure: Because we couldn't get scratch cards.
Shure: 所以就给大家买个瓜
Shure: So we bought a watermelon for everyone.
Alice:哈哈哈好谢谢
Alice: Hahaha, thanks!
Shure: 但是我买的这个盒子我已经找不到了
Shure: But I can't find the box I bought.
Shure: 怎么能给他安全的寄回去
Shure: How can I safely send it back?
Shure: 我总不能背着他背回去吧
Shure: I can't carry it on my back all the way, can I?
其他人：嗯你要是
Others: Hmm, if you...
Shure: 我不会的哈哈
Shure: I can't do that, haha.
其他人：我说你要是从学校去的话
Others: I mean, if you go from school...
其他人：晚上倒是有箱子
Others: There are boxes at night.
其他人：我还有泡沫纸
Others: I also have foam paper.
Shure: 行从你那薅薅吧
Shure: Okay, I'll get some from you.
Shure: 哎这应该也确实没有什么泡沫纸
Shure: Yeah, there's really no foam paper here.
Shure: 盒子什么的东西
Shure: Or any boxes.
其他人：你就算没有泡沫纸
Others: Even if you don't have foam paper,
其他人：你把你不需要的衣服
Others: Just use clothes you don't need
其他人：在旁边垫一下就行
Others: To cushion it on the side.
Shure: 有道理
Shure: Makes sense.
Shure: 你好聪明
Shure: You're so smart.
Shure: 你又做那个青蛙脸干什么
Shure: Why are you making that frog face again?
Shure: 帮我帮我
Shure: Help me, help me.
Shure: 低了一下这个尾巴
Shure: Lower this tail a bit.
Alice:啊啊
Alice: Ahhh.
Shure: 我们就下去吧
Shure: Let's just go down.
Shure: 被他拽折了
Shure: He broke it by pulling it.
Alice:这个也是垃圾吧
Alice: This is trash too, right?
Shure: 我上个厕所
Shure: I'm going to the bathroom.
Alice:还有个山竹
Alice: There's still a mangosteen.
其他人：天啊
Others: Oh my
Alice:给
Alice:妈的又他妈的要粘这个
Alice: Damn it, I have to stick this again.
Alice:我真是烦都烦死了
Alice: I'm so fed up with this.
其他人：实在不行什么时候检查什么时候再粘吧
Others: If it really doesn't work, stick it back when it's time for inspection.
Alice:真是脾气都上来了跟你说
Alice: Seriously, I'm getting really pissed off, I'm telling you.
Alice:干啥呀你一个鲤鱼打挺坐起来
Alice: What are you doing, sitting up like a carp flipping?
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Alice:还需要收拾什么
Alice: What else needs to be cleaned up?
Alice:牵一个凳子
Alice: Move a chair.
Alice:你好sexy
Alice: You look sexy.
Alice:我感觉我需要通通风散气
Alice: I feel like I need some fresh air.
Alice:这屋里有点闷
Alice: It's a bit stuffy in here.
Alice:真的我觉得这屋子里面真的很闷
Alice: Really, I think it's really stuffy in this room.
Alice:就一出来就感觉这个门口都是凉快的
Alice: As soon as you step out, the entrance feels so cool.
Alice:为啥你自然啥呀
Alice: Why are you acting so natural?
Alice:光有光是吗
Alice: There's light, right?
Alice:这绿色真好看啊
Alice: This green looks so nice.
Alice:是吧
Alice: Right?
其他人：好好好你有品味
Others: Yes, yes, you have good taste.
Alice:那不然呢
Alice: What else then?
Alice:啊那不然呢
Alice: Ah, what else then?
Alice:我请问呢
Alice: I'm asking you.
其他人：你是一个有品位的小姐姐
Others: You are a lady with good taste.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Miss, you...
Alice:你太太太有品位了
Alice: You have such good taste.
Alice:不是这鬼网这谁能用啊
Alice: This crappy net, who can use this?
其他人：他这自带的
Others: It came with it.
其他人：快走吧
Others: Let's go quickly.
其他人：送的眼镜啊兄弟
Others: The glasses are a gift, bro.
其他人：去吧
Others: Go ahead.
Alice:我想去二楼拉屎
Alice: I want to go to the second floor to poop.
其他人：为啥
Others: Why?
其他人：有锁
Others: It's locked.
Alice:我是一个追求生活品质的人了
Alice: I'm someone who pursues quality of life.
其他人：去吧去二楼玩吧
Others: Go, go play on the second floor.
Lucia: 他对他要扫一个连续的文件
Lucia: He needs to scan a series of documents.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 我是ready scatter
Lucia: I'm ready to scatter.
Lucia: 应该还有
Lucia: There should be more.
Lucia: 我上次那个啥的也有可能没有了
Lucia: The one I had last time might not be there anymore.
Lucia: 因为我这个软件好久没用了
Lucia: Because I haven't used this software in a long time.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:我要上个厕所
Alice: I need to use the bathroom.
Alice:这个不可以录
Alice: This can't be recorded.
Jake:好好没问题没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem, no problem.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:可以不录
Jake: We won't record it.
Jake:内有恶犬
Jake: Beware of the dog.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈可以
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:我要开始扫了可以了吗
Jake: I'm going to start scanning, is that okay?
Alice:那我下去
Alice: Then I'll go down.
Alice:把我再粘粘
Alice: Stick me again.
Jake:那你就坐着
Jake: Then just sit there.
Jake:你不能动
Jake: You can't move.
Jake:你摆个好pose
Jake: Strike a good pose.
Alice:啊给我粘胶带
Alice: Ah, tape me up.
Alice:开始扫了
Alice: Start scanning.
Alice:干嘛呢你当虫呢
Alice: What are you doing, acting like a bug?
Alice:能给我粘牢固点吗
Alice: Can you stick it more firmly?
Alice:这胶随便使
Alice: Use the tape freely.
Alice:给谢谢我躺会啊
其他人：这胶它本来就是不结实
Others: This tape isn't very strong to begin with.
Alice:那当然
Alice: Of course.
Alice:那结实不给墙皮粘掉了还得赔钱呢
Alice: If it was strong, it would rip off the wall paint and we'd have to pay for it.
Alice:谢谢你小姐姐
Alice: Thank you, young lady.
Alice:小姐姐你对我真好
Alice: Young lady, you're so nice to me.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Alice:加油刘婷加油
Alice: Go, Liu Ting, go.
Alice:刘婷加啊
Alice: Liu Ting, go for it.
Alice:你对我好点好吗
Alice: Be nicer to me, okay?
Alice:你得心疼一下我好吗
Alice: Can you show me some sympathy, please?
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Alice:给你加点音乐music
Alice: Let me add some music for you.
Alice:你可以多沾点好吗
Alice: Can you dip a bit more, please?
Alice:你确保他录的时候他不能掉
Alice: Make sure it doesn't fall off while recording.
Alice:要不然我们就白干
Alice: Otherwise, all our efforts will be wasted.
Alice:小姐姐你不会够不着吧
Alice: Miss, you can't reach it, right?
其他人：说什么呢你
Other: What are you saying?
Jake:一会我要扫这边所以
Jake: I'll sweep this area in a bit, so...
Jake:我上面可能扫他个20分钟吧
Jake: Maybe I'll sweep here for about 20 minutes.
Jake:然后20分钟之后
Jake: And then after 20 minutes...
Jake:你们就要悄悄的跑到二楼去躲着对
Jake: You guys need to quietly run to the second floor and hide, okay?
Alice:好
Alice: Sure.
Alice:我是监工
Alice: I'm the supervisor.
其他人：天呐他还得挺20分钟
Other: Oh my, he has to endure for 20 minutes.
其他人：这个胶带
Other: This tape...
其他人：我天呐对他毫无信心
Other: Oh my, I have no confidence in him.
Alice:哈哈哈那你要不多沾点
Alice: Haha, then why don't you dip a bit more?
其他人：我尽力吧
Other: I'll do my best.
其他人：哈哈哈
Other: Haha.
Alice:小姐姐你对我真好
Alice: Miss, you're so nice to me.
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Miss.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Miss, you...
Alice:对我真好
Alice: You're so nice to me.
Alice:我都要
Alice: I'm about to...
Alice:哈哈哈我还没说呢
Alice: Hahaha, I haven't even said it.
Alice:我靠我真服了
Alice: Damn, I'm really impressed.
Alice:这个窗帘真好看刘婷
Alice: These curtains are so pretty, Liu Ting.
其他人：窗帘嗯
Other: Curtains, huh?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:哦对窗帘
Alice: Oh right, curtains.
Alice:不是床帘
Alice: Not bed curtains.
Alice:是吧
其他人：挺好挺好
Other: Pretty good, pretty good.
Alice:太有品位了
Alice: So tasteful.
Alice:这什么水平
Alice: What kind of level is this?
Alice:极速神马
Alice: Speed god!
Alice:神马水平
Alice: What's going on?
Alice:请你不要到处
Alice: Please don't go around
其他人：我不是你的朋友我是你的奴隶
Others: I'm not your friend, I'm your slave
其他人：上面粘的胶带都跑哪去了
Others: Where did all the tape go?
Alice:我撕掉了
Alice: I tore it off
Alice:感觉那已经不中用了
Alice: It felt useless anyway
Alice:换新一批
Alice: Let's get a new batch
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's wrong?
Alice:不是你自愿的吗
Alice: Wasn't it voluntary?
其他人： 我就应该昨天就走了
Others: I should have left yesterday
其他人：天呐
Others: Oh my God
Alice:小姐姐你舍得吗
Alice: Girl, can you really bear to leave?
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Girl
Alice:哎呦小心点
Alice: Hey, be careful
Alice:把你摔坏了
Alice: Don't hurt yourself
Alice:我的心都痛啊
Alice: It makes my heart ache
其他人：不是我踩到我的手机了我心也痛
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:咱俩胶带有点丑
Alice: Our tape looks a bit ugly
Alice:你能把它切短一点吗
Alice: Can you cut it shorter?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
其他人：嫌弃什么你有什么资格嫌弃我问问你
Alice: Hahaha, what's there to dislike?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
其他人：我拿胶带把你嘴封闭上我应该
Others: I'll tape your mouth shut
Alice:哈哈哈sorry sorry
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:sorry哈哈哈哈哈sorry sorry
Alice: Sorry hahaha, sorry sorry
Alice:你想去长安公园野餐吗
Alice: Do you want to go for a picnic at Chang'an Park?
其他人：我时间够吗
Others: Do I have enough time?
Alice:哈哈哈咋了
Alice: Hahaha, what's wrong?
其他人：跑那喝西北风去
Others: Go there and drink the northwest wind
Alice:野餐呀
Alice: Picnic, yeah
其他人：之前还在那玩过什么跳楼机呢
Others: We even played on the drop tower there before
Alice:走呗
Alice: Let's go then
Alice:周三哎呀
Alice: Wednesday, oh
Alice:你没空我自己去
Alice: If you're busy, I'll go by myself
Alice:我上午去天坛
Alice: I'll go to the Temple of Heaven in the morning
Alice:下午去景山公园
Alice: In the afternoon, Jingshan Park
Alice:晚上去开组会
Alice: And group meeting in the evening
Alice:哈哈哈咋了
Alice: Hahaha, what's up?
其他人：也不是很紧急
Others: It's not that urgent.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
其他人：组会好像也不是很重要
Others: The group meeting doesn't seem that important either.
Alice:主要是这几天在外面心野了
Alice: Mainly, these past few days, I've been wild outside.
Alice:逃离了那个环境
Alice: I've escaped that environment.
Alice:就觉得哈哈好像跟我无关一样哈哈
Alice: I feel like it doesn't concern me at all, haha.
Alice:不行啊这是组会
Alice: No way, this is a group meeting.
Alice:我主持我还没看呢
Alice: I'm the host, I haven't even looked at it yet.
Alice:咋办呢
Alice: What should I do?
Alice:自首你是尊督吗
Alice: Are you confessing to the supervisor?
其他人：老师我错了
Others: Teacher, I was wrong.
其他人：我给你跪下老师
Others: I'm kneeling to you, teacher.
Alice:我求求你别玩抽象好吗
Alice: I'm begging you, stop playing around.
Alice:星星跟我这房间都不搭你说
Alice: The stars don't match my room, what do you think?
其他人：你藏起来
Others: You should hide them.
Alice:我也觉得
Alice: I think so too.
Alice:把这个也给插上
Alice: Plug this in too.
Alice:叮叮
Alice: Ding ding.
其他人：到点了吗
Others: Is it time?
Alice:没呢
Alice: Not yet.
Alice:爽
Alice: Nice.
其他人：嗯臀部敲到黑鼻子上个心
Others: Yeah, the hip hit the black nose.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Alice:真嘟假嘟
Alice: Really or not?
Alice:queen car
Alice: Queen car.
Alice:舒服
Alice: Comfortable.
Alice:我靠真的很舒服
Alice: Oh my god, it's really comfortable.
Alice:再来点
Alice: A bit more.
Alice:嗯来嘛
Alice: Yeah, come on.
Alice:一条腿
Alice: One leg.
Alice:我还没去紫竹苑公园玩过
Alice: I haven't been to Zizhuyuan Park yet.
Alice:木绣球和流苏
Alice: Mock orange and fringe tree.
Alice:这花我还没见过呢
Alice: I haven't seen these flowers before.
Alice:往身上弄呗可爽了
Alice: Put it on your body, it's so nice.
Alice:腰那
Alice: The waist, there.
Alice:太牛逼了
Alice: That's awesome.
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Ouch.
Alice:我是girl
Alice: I'm a girl.
其他人：ok girl
Other people: Okay girl
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Ouch
Alice:我困了
Alice: I'm sleepy
其他人：困了睡呗
Other people: If you're sleepy, then sleep
其他人：别睡了别睡
Other people: Don't sleep, don't sleep
其他人：臭宝宝
Other people: Stinky baby
Alice:恶心死了
Alice: So gross
Alice:臭狗屎你
Alice: You stinky poop
Alice:你告诉我这是你的脚
Alice: Are you telling me this is your foot?
Alice:你放什么屁呢
Alice: What kind of fart is that?